congratulations again after this before
but your show review very funny a great
idea this guy that wants to review life
experiences and then ruins the lives of
everyone around him including his own
including himself yes yes completely
ruined his own life he's had to get
divorced for the shows you saw he had to
get addicted to cocaine he's been shot
with arrows just how to eat a
six-month-old burrito and yeah yeah yeah
he's an idiot but you know it's funny
because I'm always very happy for you
that you've you've done so well because
I first met you when you started doing
sketches for our show
way back when it was the late night show
in New York yeah you were you did so
many sketches for us I did yes it was
like the only job you were the only
place I would hire me to do anything
yeah it was exciting we had I don't know
if you remembered what was your most you
have a sketch that you remember that
sort of sticks out for you for either
good or bad reasons well yeah there was
one sketch that I think about often
where I was called and told in this guy
remember what the bit was but I was told
Rob Riggle is gonna give you a swirly
right in a toilet you know you hold
somebody upside down and flush the
toilet you know like what we can't do it
today because we got to find a prop
toilet so we'll call you when we can and
I was like all right and then they
called me said alright come on down
we're gonna do the bit and they didn't
find a proper toilet they just took me
to one of the bathrooms on the sixth
floor will help me upside down over a
real toilet to poop in
that is that is so us it's so us it was
like it was there prompted I can just
put dunk his head in a regular
you